The weird thing is: when I'm this close,
my whole point of reference becomes the
spinning aluminum and the painting, and so
at certain parts of feels like the
rest of the room is spinning in the
opposite direction.
My name is Dana Haugaard and I teach
Visual Arts
through the Art History Department at Emory University.
So my main area of research is thinking about
how we exist with ourselves in spaces. So
I create installations in art that [try]
to focus your attention back to your
physical presence in a space.
Some of the work is designed to just show yourself to yourself.
Other work is kind of made to subvert your expectation
of the reflection. So either your reflection is reversed
or it is wildly stretched out, or in some of the works you even look at it
and you know it's a mirror, but your
reflection is denied because the mirrors
are at an angle. So you're not expecting
to see what you see.
This body of work is--I call them paintings for lack of a
better word--but really they're kind of
very small installations. They're a
series of concentric circles painted on
mirrors that kind of incorporate you and
the environment into the work. And you're
kind of viewing yourself and the
environment through this filter of these
circle patterns that I've layered on to
the surface of the mirrors. I kind of
forget that I'm a physical presence in
space sometimes and I think a lot of us do.
And to be confronted with an
experience of your physical presence in
space that is unexpected, kind of jarring
you back into the realization that you
are present, I think is a really
important thing to think about right now.
With this large concave piece, I kind of
decided on a phrase to say and then kind of
repeated it over and kind of plotted
how the sound would travel through space
as I was saying it and then plotted it
onto
the mirrors.
All of these kind of
mirrored paintings are kind of a very
laborious process, where it looks like it
could be printed or etched by a computer,
but it's all--they're all hand done line
work. You know, mask.
Plot.
Cut.
Paint.
This sculpture with the hula hoop, it's kind
of in the same series of these works
kind of thinking about memory and kind
of nostalgia. I spent so much time trying
to teach myself how to move in this
weird undulating way.
And then, when I did it was great.
It's like this weird,
useless task that you only really do to have fun.
I've just installed a work at the Zuckerman Museum of Art at Kennesaw State University.
And it really is about
kind of deconstructing and recontextualizing
memory and nostalgia. It's a video and
sound-based work where I ran a light
bulb out into the woods and put a very
sensitive microphone under it and taped it.
I did it every night for two weeks.
And what I was recording were moths
flying to this light. And it didn't
record the sound of the moths and other
bugs, but it recorded kind of the air
displacement that their wings created.
And a lot of the sound work I do isn't
really audible it's sensorial. I take
audio and convert it into physical
vibrations or sensation.
So, in this installation the video is presented and
all of the audio is run through these
chairs that I made and all the audio of
the moths flying to this light kind of
create this full-body sensorial
experience as you're sitting in this
chair--where you know your presence in
this space is really anchored to your
physicality in the space.
It's a it's a universal kind of memory I
think that people sit and kill time
staring at bugs hitting a light bulb. I
think everyone has probably done that at
some point in their lives, when their
phone's broken. But it's it's definitely
a constructed memory and so trying to
kind of highlight and show that this is...
it's an important memory, but it's not
real. And it's okay to feel comfort in
this, but you have to kind of go back into
reality when it's done.